die lichtgeschwindigkeit ist
unveränderbar das ist die basis der
speziellen und allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie diese konstante
verformt raum und zeit
viele haben nach der erklärung der
relativitätstheorie gefragt hier ist
sie den krieg zum science fiction nicht
bewegt sich exakt mit einer
geschwindigkeit von 2.999 7 192
kilometern pro sekunde
nicht mehr und nicht weniger unter
keinen umständen das hat dramatische
folgen
die spezielle relativitätstheorie von
albert einstein ein prinzip der physik
ist das prinzip des sozialsystems
das heißt an allen orten an denen ich
nicht beschleunigt werden sind die
bedingungen gleich egal ob ich mit 800
kilometern pro stunde im flugzeug über
die erde jetta oder im büro auf der
couch sitze ich kann meinen kaffee
überall in ruhe trinken
der kaffee fliegt mit der gleichen
geschwindigkeit wie ich und das flugzeug
wenn ich im flugzeug mit sechs
kilometern pro stunde nach vorne zur
toilette gehe bewege ich mich mit rund
insgesamt 806 kilometern pro stunde
da sich geschwindigkeiten agieren wenn
nicht aber immer eine konstante
geschwindigkeit hat habe ich ein problem
zur lichtgeschwindigkeit kann keine
geschwindigkeit addiert werden
sie ist sehr konstant sie kann weder 800
kilometer schneller werden wenn sich
nicht im flugzeug ausbreitet noch 8 106
kilometer es muss also andere
konsequenzen haben
und es gibt nur eine lösung das
flugzeug wird in bewegungsrichtung so
stark zusammengedrückt dass die
lichtgeschwindigkeit an bord genauso
hoch sein kann wie außerhalb des
flugzeugs die entfernung im flugzeug
müssen so verkürzt werden dass das
licht sich eben nicht
800 kilometer pro stunde schneller
bewegen muss der raum wird
zusammengedrückt hohe geschwindigkeiten
drücken den raum zusammen längen
kontraktion wird das genannt aber auch
die zeit wird verändert fliege ich
über deutschland sehe ich wie das licht
längere distanzen zurückgelegt als am
boden
während für den beobachter am boden
der abstand zwischen zwei objekten immer
gleich bleibt sind die abstände für
mich größer fliege ich zum beispiel
bei frankfurt
verschieben sich die punkte von denen
licht aus gesendet wird und die punkte
an denen das licht an kommt während ich
über die stadt fliegen
das licht ist aus meiner sicht einen
längeren weg zurück da liegt aber
nicht in derselben zeit einen längeren
weg zurücklegen kann muss sich die zeit
bei mir an bord verlängern damit das
licht diesen längeren weg auch
zurücklegen kann
die konsequenz ist also auch hier
dramatisch die zeit an bord muss
langsamer vergehen als am boden
eine reise mit dem flugzeug ist also
auch immer eine zeitreise in die zukunft
während auf der erde zum beispiel ein
jahr vergeht sind es an bord eines
schnellen raumschiffes zum beispiel nur
364 tage weil die zeit eben an dort
langsamer vergeht im hafen keating
experiment wurde das 1971 nachgewiesen
hoch exakte caesium atomuhren wurden an
bord eines linienflugzeuges gebracht und
nach flügen um die erde wurden sie mit
atomuhren die sie stationär auf der
erde befanden verglichen und
tatsächlich gingen die uhren an bord
langsamer hohe geschwindigkeiten
verlangsamen die zeit
das heißt da die lichtgeschwindigkeit
zurzeit dehnung führt hat das noch eine
weitere konsequenz auch bei einem sehr
schnell fliegenden asteroiden der auf
einem planeten einschlägt vergeht die
zeit langsamer aus seiner perspektive
ist die einschlags geschwindigkeit also
geringer ob bei ihm läuft die zeit
langsamer ab als bei einem
außenstehenden trotzdem ist der
einschlag für beide beobachter gleich
stark daraus ergibt sich eine weitere
konsequenz umso schneller sich materie
bewegt desto schwerer wird sie bewegte
objekte haben deshalb eine größere
masse auch das grundlegende folgen wenn
ich also energie in masse stecke um sie
zu beschleunigen wird ein teil der
energie in masse umgesetzt masse
entspricht also energie und das eine
kann in das andere umgewandelt werden
gleich ma c quadrat energie
bis gleich masse mal
lichtgeschwindigkeit in quadrath bei
einem kilo materie heißt dass ein
kilogramm x 299.000 192 kilometer pro
sekunde hoch zwei
das sind 89 millionen kilojoule damit
können neun kubikkilometer wasser um
einen meter angehoben werden es sind
also unmengen energie in wasser
enthalten diese energie ist in der form
von bindungskräfte zwischen den
bestandteilen der atomkerne neutronen
und protonen vorhanden
die grundlagen für die kernspaltung
damit für atombomben und kernkraftwerke
war als theorie entwickelt worden
aber ein stein gab nicht ruhe er
verallgemeinerte die
relativitätstheorie zur allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie die konstante
lichtgeschwindigkeit hat nämlich eine
weitere konsequenz die gravitation auch
licht wird in das gravitationsfeld von
massereichen körpern gezogen
das heißt im gravitationsfeld wird
nicht beschleunigt und das bedeutet alle
folgerungen aus der speziellen
relativitätstheorie können auf
gravitations felder verallgemeinert
werden
das heißt die zeit die nation
gravitations felder verlangsamen die
zeit wenn er wie er der erde sind desto
langsamer vergeht die zeit unsere füße
sind also jünger als unser kopf für
die füße gehen die uhren langsamer bei
der programmierung von geostationären
satelliten muss genau das
berücksichtigt werden sie kreisen in
36.000 kilometern höhe
wodurch die zeit bei ihnen schneller
abläuft bei ihrer programmierung muss
das jetzt genau berücksichtigt werden
sonst würden zum beispiel gps
navigations satelliten unsere
navigationssysteme vollkommen in die
irre führen
und auch ein zweiter grundsatz der
speziellen relativitätstheorie gilt nun
eins zu eins gravitations felder
drücken den raum zusammen
die mengen konstruktion das ist wirklich
papieren wir hier erleben in form der
erdanziehungskraft ganz konkret die
allgemeine relativitätstheorie
denn die schrumpfung des raums ist
nichts anderes als die kraft die uns auf
die erde zieht mit anderen worten weil
das licht eine konstante geschwindigkeit
hat wer die wir von der erde angezogen
nochmal zum mitschreiben licht kann sich
nicht schneller als mit 299 1792
kilometern pro sekunde ausbreiten wird
es von einem gravitationsfeld angezogen
sind zwei dinge die konsequenz die zeit
wird langsamer weil ich nicht schneller
werden kann und der raum wird gestaut
weil licht in einem zeitabschnitt keine
größeren distanzen zurücklegen kann
das ergebnis wir erleben diese stauchung
des raums diese raum krümmung als
anziehungskraft gibt es noch mehr raum
täglich dafür hier klicken also gibt
es für android und ios
den gibt's natürlich auch in der video
beschreibung wie auch den zum thema
schwarzes loch das video hier
da spielt auch die relativitätstheorie
eine riesenrolle was meint ihr ist die
relativitätstheorie wirklich eine
stichhaltige theorie oder hat sich ein
stein wird diskutiert es in den
kommentaren
und was bleibt noch zu sagen ich würde
mal sagen bis dann bleibt dran